Là, on a un problème.
Vous savez que c’est une obligation légale d’aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras.
C’est qu’il y a de la place dans le congel. On a qu’à la mettre là dedans en attendant.
Tu sais Valentine,
dommage que ta cousine ait pas été à l’Académie française quand même.
Pourquoi tu me dis ça ?
Parce qu’elle serait devenue immortelle !
Non mais ça va pas ?
Non mais les académiciens leur surnom, c’est les immortels, c’est une blague.
Parce que la cousine de Valentine, elle peut pas être immortelle parce qu'elle est morte.
Nan, c’est pas drôle.
Arrête.
Nan mais c’est vrai que j’y suis pas allé de la main morte.
Nan mais arrête tu vas faire pleurer Valentine !
Ouais non vous avez raison,
désolé Valentine.
Tu veux que je fasse un temps
mort ?
Non mais arrête, Florence a raison, en plus si les gens n’ont pas vu les autres épisodes, ils vont rien comprendre.
Mort de rire !
Dans le premier épisode de cette saison, Valentine vous a parlé de rire et de ses caractéristiques générales ou universelles.
Pourtant, y’a une réponse à laquelle elle n’a pas répondu et qui moi me travaille un peu.
Peut-on rire de tout ?
Normalement, à la simple évocation de cette phrase vous pensez à Desproges,
vous me répondez alors que oui mais pas avec tout le monde, et vous êtes déjà en train de vous charpiller dans les commentaires ou sur Twitter,
parce que du temps de Coluche on était libre alors que maintenant avec le politiquement correct à cause de ces co...
la question est intéressante.
Mais lorsque l’on y répond, c’est toujours sur les mêmes aspects, et moi ça m’ennuie.
Parce qu’il y en a un qu’on explore jamais, et qui à moi me parait évident.
L’humour est-il lié à la culture, ou à la langue ?
Après tout, peut-être bien qu’on ne peut pas rire de tout avec tout le monde.
Tout simplement parce qu’en ayant des langues maternelles différentes, des cultures différentes,
on ne peut pas être tous réceptifs aux mêmes vannes.
Vous avez forcément entendu parler d’humour anglais,
vous vous êtes peut-être déjà surpris à penser que les allemands n’avaient pas d’humour,
et pour les plus téméraires vous avez peut-être même tenté une sitcom russe qui vous a laissé perplexe.
Dès l’antiquité, on s’était penché sur la question.
Cicéron distingait deux types d’humour, à savoir le de re et le de dicto, soit littéralement le rire “des choses”
et le rire “du dit”.
Cette distinction, on la fait toujours mais on la nomme avec des concepts différemment.
On parle désormais plutôt d’humour référentiel d’un côté, et d’humour verbal de l’autre.
L’humour référentiel, c’est celui qui se base sur le contexte essentiellement et ne dépend pas de composantes linguistiques,
tandis que l’humour verbal lui en dépend directement.
Ça va mieux ?
- T'as parlé de Cicéron là non ?
- Oui ?
Tu sais que si c’est rond, c’est poincaré ?
Non !
C’est drôle, parce qu’en fait, y a carré dedans.
Et Poincaré, c’est un mec, il a
fait des trucs dans l’histoire de France.
C’est beaucoup trop long.
il est né à Bar-Le-Duc.
Et c’est beaucoup trop triste en plus de ça.
La blague de Valentine est terrible de médiocrité, on est d’accord,
mais il n’en reste pas moins qu’elle se base sur des éléments strictement linguistiques
à savoir la prononciation en français de deux noms
et de leur homophonie avec d’autres mots de la langue.
Cicéron / si c’est rond.
Les deux énoncés se transcrivent strictement identiquement en écriture phonétique,
et c’est là tout ce qu’ils ont en commun.
C’est clairement de dicto,
c’est de l’humour verbal.
Ma réaction, si elle vous a fait sourire, relève en revanche du de re, de l’humour référentiel.
Parce que le mec est né à Bar-le-Duc et je crois que j’ai pas tant besoin d’expliquer pourquoi c’est drôle.
Parce que Bar-le-Duc quoi.
Vous avez déjà été à Bar-le-Duc ?
Est-ce que vous avez été dans la Meuse ?
Fatalement, l’humour verbal est dépendant de la langue sur laquelle il se base.
Si je tente de l’humour verbal dans une autre langue, une langue que vous ne parlez pas,
je serais bien emmerdé pour vous expliquer en quoi c’est sensé vous arracher un sourire.
Si je dois en venir aux explications,
on aura de toute façon troqué la galéjade par un moment de malaise.
Voilà, comme celui-là.
Bref, par essence, l’humour qui se base sur la langue exclut de fait ceux qui ne la parle pas.
Dans ce cas précis, il est légitime de dire qu’on peut rire de tout,
mais pas avec tout le monde.
Hey Valentine.
What is black and white and red all over ?
A newspaper.
J’ai pas compris.
Si black and white, c’est des couleurs. Tu vois, c’est noir et blanc.
Et red, ça veut dire rouge, mais ça veut dire lu…
parce que c’est un journal.
C’est un jeu de mot !
Oui voilà, c’est ça. C’est un jeu de mot,
c’est marrant du coup. C’est un peu drôle.
- Je ne parle pas super bien anglais en fait.
- Ah ok super !
Donc toi, tu es journaliste scientifique, mais tu ne parles pas anglais.
Trop bien, moi j’ai envie de t’applaudir.
Venez applaudir Valentine !
Traduire ce genre de blagues est bien souvent impossible.
Comme l’humour verbal peut aussi tirer profit d’une situation donnée,
ou rebondir sur des mots qui ont pu être dit quelques phrases auparavant,
les traducteurs de sitcom américaines s’arrachent les cheveux pour restituer au mieux non pas le texte original,
mais la réaction que ce texte est censé susciter.
Parce qu’une bonne traduction n’est pas forcément littérale,
et même surtout pas dans le cas de l’humour verbal.
Et si beaucoup préfèrent l’original à la VF, je suis désolé mais des fois la VF fait très bien le taf et même surpasse la VO.
J’invoque South Park comme exemple.
Est-ce que tu vas la déglacer cette putain de poêle
On va se faire dégommer en commentaire, je vous préviens !
Parfois, il faut accepter que l’on ne puisse tout simplement pas restituer cet humour dans une autre langue.
Parce qu’il dépend trop du contexte culturel, parce qu’il est trop ancré dans un univers linguistique,
parce qu’il exploite des codes trop spécifiques et non transposables à l’étranger.
C’est le cas de Kaamelott, par exemple.
L’un des programmes les plus cultes et des plus drôles des années 2000 pour beaucoup de francophones.
Mais qui n’a pas su trouver son public à l’étranger, dans d’autres langues.
Je ne donne pas cet exemple au hasard : Il y a quelques temps, je suis tombé sur un article de The Independant qui m’a pas mal marqué.
Une journaliste ayant grandi en France y parlait de sa difficulté à faire comprendre à son mari américain pourquoi cette série la faisait rire.
Il se trouve que Kaamelott exploite énormément le détournement de collocations ou de locutions figées.
Les collocations sont des termes qui fonctionnent souvent ensemble dans la langue,
comme “main crochue”, “courir vite”, “voix grave”, “casser les noix”.
Lorsque ces termes ne peuvent plus fonctionnement indépendamment l’un de l’autre sans trahir le sens général de l’expression, on parle alors de locution figée,
comme “pomme-de-terre”, “hôtel-de-ville”, “le dindon de la farce”.
D'ailleurs, je n'ai jamais compris cette histoire de dindon et de farce.
Faudra qu’on m’explique.
Dans le langage courant, les gens parlent souvent d’expressions ou même d’expressions toute faite.
Et d’ailleurs “expression toute faite”, c’est une expression toute faite.
Et ça, c’est marrant.
Pour résumer, le détournement de collocations ou de locutions figées, c’est quand l’on prend une expression française, que l’on y substitue des mots par d’autres mots proches
ou qui en tout cas permettent de préserver le sens global, et ce afin de créer un décalage.
Ne dites pas “en plein dans sa gueule” mais “en plein dans sa mouille”,
ne dites pas “je voudrais pas faire mon relou” mais “je voudrais pas faire ma raclette”.
Vous obtenez le principal ressort comique de Kaamelott.
Tout le personnage de Perceval est construit sur ce modèle d’ailleurs.
C’est pas faux !
Plus généralement, une partie de l’humour de la série repose sur les registres de langue.
Le registre, c’est la façon de vous exprimer en fonction d’une situation sociale particulière,
et cela concerne aussi bien le choix des mots, la construction de la phrase ou l’intonation que vous allez prendre.
C’est un peu comme les habits, on se fringue pas pareil pour un entretien d’embauche dans un cabinet d’avocat que pour la soirée pizza du Denis.
Et les registres sont rarement mélangés, sauf lorsque l’on cherche à créer un décalage.
Exemple :
Mais vous êtes pas mort, espèce de connard ?
Ou encore :
si je vous dis que vous êtes deux glands, là, vous avez du péremptoire.
Ici, le vouvoiement et le lexique soutenu, qui donne un côté ancien,
viennent trancher avec la vulgarité populaire de termes très actuels.
Le film “les visiteurs” utilisait les mêmes ressorts comiques quelques années auparavant d’ailleurs,
et si l’on regarde par exemple la version espagnole du film,
on se rend compte que souvent les références linguistiques et l’humour lié aux registres n’a pas pu être conservé.
Des tournures volontairement fautives ou ambiguës dans la version française ont été corrigées dans la version espagnole par exemple,
cela explique peut-être pourquoi le film a d’ailleurs une étoile de moins sur Filmaffinity españa que sur allociné.
Que ce soit dans Kaamelott ou dans Les Visiteurs,
ce ressort comique linguistique fonctionne extrêmement bien en français parce que cela exploite des particularités grammaticales
et un contexte culturel particulier, mais que l’on ne retrouve pas vraiment en Espagne, en Angleterre, aux Etats-Unis.
De toute façon, les registres populaires ou familiers sont difficiles à traduire ou à adapter,
parce qu’ils contiennent une information objective en plus d’une information sociale.
Ils sont le fruit d’évolutions linguistiques laissées dans les mains de l’usage.
Tout ça pour dire, difficile de faire comprendre aux anglo-saxons pourquoi “pas changer assiette pour fromage”
est à mourir de rire.
Ou Arthour Couillère ou ce genre de chose.
En fait tu vois, une même marque, d’un pays à l’autre, ne va pas forcément communiquer avec de l’humour.
avec de l’humour.
Déjà, dans le cas d’une grosse marque, d’une multinationale, etc., tu vas forcément avoir un siège social
dans un peu tous les pays, et en plus un département marketing dans ce pays
qui va être lié à une agence de comm spécifique à ce pays-là.
Et ça, c’est super important, parce que forcément, tu ne vas pas communiquer de la même façon, parce que
tu n’as pas forcément les mêmes concurrents dans un pays,
tu n’as pas forcément la même cible à viser, pour x ou y raisons,
et du coup, tu n’as surtout pas les mêmes moeurs, la même culture,
et donc pas la même manière de s’adresser aux gens, pas les mêmes objectifs aussi pour la marque.
Une même marque dans un pays peut être leader et pas du tout dans un autre, ce genre de choses.
Après, tu as quand même des grosses campagnes internationales qui vont tourner dans plein de pays à grosses échelles
et qui vont juste être récupérées et traduites localement par ces agences de comm.
Ils vont dire : “OK, on a du chouette visuel, de chouettes extraits vidéo,
on va redoubler par dessus”.
C’est pour ça que d’ailleurs, tu as des pubs qui sont un peu doublées de manière dégueulasse,
sans synchro au niveau des lèvres ou ce genre de trucs.
Mais enfin mon chéri, ce sont trois choses en même temps, tu sais.
Et dans le cas de l’humour, c’est vachement compliqué.
Parce que si tu as du jeu de mot, c’est vraiment ce qu’il y a de plus difficile à adapter.
Si tu as vraiment une marque qui dit : “OK, on va communiquer dans tous les pays avec des trucs à base de jeux de mot”,
c’est pratiquement impossible.
Et ce cas-là, ça peut arriver au sein d’un même pays, parce que par exemple en Belgique, n’importe quelle campagne de comm,
elle doit être traduite en français et en néerlandais.
Forcément, tu évites le jeu de mot,
ou alors tu dois le penser en amont,
en disant : “OK, on a un bon jeu de mot en français, est-ce qu’on en a un aussi bien
en néerlandais et est-ce que ça veut dire la même chose, est-ce que ça transmet le même truc, etc.”
Voilà, l’humour dans le cadre de la comm, en tout cas,
est clairement culturel. Eh oui.
Mais si on ne peut pas traduire efficacement l’humour verbal, ni le restituer,
peut-on au moins l’apprendre ?
Peut-on apprendre l’humour verbal ?
Si apprendre une langue peut déjà vous paraître difficile,
je suis désolé de vous dire que la maîtrise de jeux de mots est un exercice bien plus dur encore.
Maîtriser l’humour verbal, cela demande de maîtriser la langue dans laquelle celui-ci prend place.
De très bien la maîtriser, même.
Pour cela, il ne faut pas être en insécurité linguistique,
c’est-à-dire qu’il ne faut pas ressentir de malaise lorsque l’on parle, ni la peur de faire une erreur.
Au contraire, il faut être extrêmement confiant dans son niveau et dans sa capacité à être compris.
Et rien que ça, c’est un gros morceau. Parce que lorsque l’on parle une langue étrangère, c’est rarement le cas.
Par ailleurs, si vous tentez de faire un jeu de mots dans une langue qui n’est pas votre langue maternelle,
on aura peut-être tendance à partir du principe que vous avez confondu deux termes,
ou que vous avez mélangé deux expressions, et que cela n’est pas intentionnel.
En tant que non-natif, sachez que vous subirez une présomption à la faute.
Aux yeux des autres, des natifs, vous n’aurez pas fait un trait d’humour,
vous vous serez trompé et c’est ça qui leur sera drôle.
Ils attendront de vous que vous utilisiez la bonne prononciation, la bonne intonation,
l’utilisation des registres populaires ou familiers vous fera passer pour un amateur.
Peut-être vous faudra-t-il alors insister, expliquer votre trait d’humour, ce qui en soi n’est jamais optimal quand on veut juste faire sourire les gens.
Ce simple fait peut déjà vous en dissuader.
Si vous trouvez ce présupposé raciste ou ethnocentré de la part de vos amis ou de votre auditoire,
si vous trouvez que cela met à mal votre intégration dans une autre communauté linguistique, je ne vous contredirais pas.
En revanche, c’est assez facilement explicable.
Renversons la balance :
En mandarin, beaucoup de mots ne se distinguent que par les tons,
c’est-à-dire que beaucoup de mots sont identiques en tout point si ce n’est dans l’intonation avec laquelle ils sont prononcés.
Nous Européens avons beaucoup de mal avec cela,
nous Francophones tout particulièrement.
Imaginez que vous vouliez parler du cheval de l’herbe et de la boue, un mème répandu sur l’internet chinois,
qui se dit cǎo ní mǎ mais qu’à la place vous dites
cào nǐ mā
c’est-à-dire “nique ta mère”.
cǎo ní mǎ... cào nǐ mā...
Il est probable que je vienne de dire “nique ta mère” en mandarin aux gens sur youtube là,
ça passe ?
Malaise. Même si vous l’avez fait exprès.
Même si vous avez voulu être drôle. Comme moi en écrivant ce script. Coup dur.
L’humour verbal en mandarin exploite beaucoup cette caractéristique linguistique.
Il se trouve que le premier terme, censé désigner une espèce d’alpaga et qui fut à l’origine d’un véritable phénomène culturel en Chine,
est un jeu de mot justement tiré du second terme qui est une insulte.
Comme il se trouve que nous autres européens avons tendance à ne jamais bien prononcer ni l’un, ni l’autre,
il est légitime pour les chinois de croire que, en fonction du contexte, nous parlons de l’un ou de l’autre.
Et que nous nous trompions souvent. Sans faire exprès.
Que selon eux, nous voulions surement dire l’autre phrase,
celle qui leur paraît la bonne.
J’imagine que dans beaucoup de cas, cela nous sauve plus que le contraire.
Croyez-moi, j’ai connu ce genre de situation quand je vivais en Autriche.
Là, à ce moment, je voulais écrire une petite scénette et tout mais vous allez rien comprendre.
Parce que c’est en allemand.
C’est intraduisible.
Parce que tout ce qu’on vient déjà de dire dans l’épisode.
J’vais me taire sinon on va encore dire que les bilingues ils se la racontent trop.
Faux !
De toute façon, même en cas de maitrise parfaite de la langue,
il en reste une qui reste déterminante pour saisir et faire de l’humour en langue étrangère.
Maitrisez-vous le contexte culturel ?
Il se trouve qu’à l’école, on apprend avant tout les langues vivantes sous un aspect fonctionnel et utilitaire,
et si on apprend parfois un peu de culture,
que les anglais ont des bus rouges et que les allemands mangent des saucisses par exemple,
ce n’est jamais au centre de l’enseignement.
Alors on pourrait débattre pour savoir si c’est un bien ou un mal, toujours est-il qu’on est de toute façon limité par le temps scolaire
et qu’on est en dehors de l’immersion linguistique qui serait nécessaire.
Bah ouais, c’est pas une heure de cours de langue avec un prof qui vont remplacer la vie au pays.
Surtout si on est 30 élèves francophones monolingues et qu’on va au collège à Bar-le-duc.
Et sans avoir accès aux références culturelles, sans connaître les petits phrases drôles tirées de telle série ou de tel film,
difficile de saisir l’humour d’une situation et encore plus dur de le reproduire sans que ça tape à côté et donc sans passer pour un blaireau.
Évidemment, aujourd’hui l’impérialisme linguistique de l’anglais conduit à un lissage des références culturels,
en imposant l’humour qui lui est lié à tous les pays sous influence anglo-saxonne, comme un socle commun.
Enfin sauf à Bar-le-duc. L’anglais s’y impose pas de ouf là-bas.
La surexposition à la langue anglaise nous conduit à en adopter également les codes.
C’est vrai, en Occident en tout cas.
Parce que, pour autant, l’humour en Extrême-Orient reste particulièrement différent.
Dans notre sphère culturelle eurocentrée, être drôle est quelque chose de positif
et c’est même un trait de personnalité qui nous rend plus désirable, plus motivant,
plus capable et plus créatif aux yeux des autres.
En Chine par contre, où le confucianisme a joué un rôle important,
l’humour est bien moins perçu et être drôle n’est pas considéré comme un trait de personnalité souhaitable, ni une source de créativité d’ailleurs,
et c’est plutôt considéré comme une faculté réservée à certaines personnes expertes de l’exercice.
Cela va même plus loin.
Le type d’humour utilisé ou le but que sert cet humour dépend de votre culture.
Par exemple, le fait de réduire le stress via l’humour est un très trait occidental,
et si vous tentez d’utiliser ce moyen dans le milieu professionnel en Chine, cela risque de mal passer.
D’ailleurs, même chez les enfants, les Chinois ont tendance à percevoir l’humour comme un signe d’agression pouvant mettre en péril la cohésion de groupe,
contrairement aux enfants canadiens par exemple, de culture européenne, qui eux le perçoivent positivement.
Au-delà de votre bonne maîtrise linguistique donc, sans maîtriser les arcanes culturelles du milieu où vous évoluez,
votre humour peut totalement être déplacé.
D’ailleurs, plusieurs pays partagent la même langue sans que la culture soit totalement identique.
Un film de comédie espagnol ne fait pas forcément rire en Amérique du sud,
une sitcom américaine ne fait pas forcément rire en Ecosse.
On parlait de la traduction des oeuvres humoristiques tout à l’heure, mais on pourrait également parler des remakes qui ne sont pas forcément une mauvaise idée,
même au sein du même espace linguistique.
Vous connaissez surement Caméra Café par exemple, la série télé diffusée de 2001 à 2004 sur M6.
Et bien sachez qu’elle a été adaptée au Québec et diffusée de 2002 à 2012,
soit pendant 10 ans !
Le succès de la version outratlantique est sans aucun doute dû à l’adaptation,
qui avait toutes les possibilités d’exploiter les références culturelles locale.
Bref, l’humour verbal peut donc théoriquement s’apprendre.
Mais si vous comptiez faire une carrière d’humoriste aux Etats-Unis et voir votre one-man-show en anglais finir sur Netflix d’ici 2 ans,
autant vous dire que vous partez de loin et avec pas mal de handicaps.
Surtout si on part de Bar-le-duc !
Mange tes morts Valentine.
Tu manges bien tes morts.
Voilà, tu manges tes morts, et tu t’en vas.
Nan mais Monté, on en a déjà parlé, tu peux pas dire mange tes morts et surtout pas à quelqu’un qui vient de perdre un proche.
C’était pour rire.
Nan mais c’est pas drôle en fait !
J’suis sûr que ça a fait rire un ou deux guguss ou deux devant son ordi.
Elle vient de perdre quelqu’un de sa famille quand même.
La prochaine fois je lui dirai : ät dina döda.
Ca veut dire quoi?
Mange tes morts, en suédois
Mais les Suédois, c’est un peuple safe.
Ils mangent du renne.
Mais sans sortir d’Europe, même sans quitter la France,
le contexte culturel peut vraiment vous mettre en difficulté pour comprendre l’humour.
Parce que si la langue est une barrière nette, et si les cultures étrangères représentent aussi des ensembles assez bien conceptualisables,
la culture en France n’est pas uniforme.
un notaire de Paris n’aura pas les mêmes références culturelles qu’un ouvrier de...
de Bar-le-Duc par exemple. Ou de Vierzon.
Pour changer tiens. Ou de Valenciennes.
Les références peuvent être diverses, transcender les classes sociales ou non,
être régionalisées ou non.
L’humour sert alors aussi, au sein d’une même communauté linguistique,
à se positionner socialement.
C’est quelque chose qui n’est alors pas monolithique ni uniforme au sein des pays ou des cultures dont nous avons parlé,
ce qui rajoute évidemment une autre couche de complexité.
Si cet épisode vous a plu, si vous avez ri,... ou pas.
N’hésitez pas à aller sur Discord pour en parler évidemment.
Le lien est en description.
Vous pouvez vous abonner, mettre la cloche, liker, commenter, partager.
Et voilà.
De toutes façons, je suis sûr que si Valentine n’est pas sensible à mon humour, c’est parce que c’est une bourgeoise qui vient de j’sais pas quelle ville, genre,
Bordeaux.
Non, ça, c’est parce que tu es désagréable.
C'est bon, y a pas mort d'homme.
Si justement.
Nan, y’a mort de femme déjà !
OK, moi ce que je propose, c’est qu’on arrête de rigoler de ça, on arrête de faire des blagues là-dessus, genre vraiment.
Ouais, parce que c’est chiant.
Eh bien salut, oui, c'est moi, c'est moi chez moi,
c'est moi chez moi depuis Twitch, c'est moi sur Twitch actuellement.
Et comme c'était annoncé sur Instagram d'ailleurs.
Si jamais vous voulez discuter de ce sujet, si ce sujet vous a plus,
si ce sujet vous a intéressé, sachez que vous pouvez venir en débattre.
pour venir dire ce que vous en avez pensé, et tutti quanti finalement.
et sur ce, et bien,
bonne soirée à vous.